oui comme ayew président du club de
l'information africaine bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin
alors on vient d'entendre un l'opposant
moby lines qui a dénoncé des fraudes
électorales une mascarade complète
affirme-t-il des accusations mois a
fondé sur vous oui parce que quand on
voit une main violence dans lequel
vivait s'est déroulé et surtout est pure
des tarnais qui de est une
quand on entend un organisme l'exigé sur
le panafricain c'est qu'on voit à peu
près à qui profite le crime mais on voit
à peu près qu'est ce que le même
mécanisme est mis en place lorsque les
pouvoirs ne sont pas certains de
remporter des élections et donc le crime
est signée en quelque sorte
justement vous promet de fournir des
vidéos de ses preuves de ces fraudes
pardon une fois l'accès internet rétabli
quelles preuves petit elle a disposé
j'espère pour lui qu'il enleva en l'air
et je pense que surtout peu on a entendu
les observateurs électoraux qui se
plaignaient de n'avoir pas vu la
capacité de transmettre les élections de
2 30 m de résultat de vérifier dans
quelles conditions
tout cela était organisé transmis donc
il est évident que s'il a eu des
observateurs suffisamment vivant ou
suivre le processus qui l'a probablement
amassé preuves suffisantes donc montrer
au moins dans certaines odeurs qui a eu
des tricheries ou des anomalies dans à
la fois le l'élection elle-même
l'organisme lecture la transmission des
résultats
maintenant reste à savoir quelle est
l'ampleur de cette robe est ce qu'elle
est de nature à changer le sens du vote
populaire
toute la question est là a fait 18 ans
que ce ne sont pas des élections dont on
pourrait certifié aujourd'hui le parti
cité et dire quelle forme il parle moi
l'expression du peuple où aller
vous savez ni qui reste donc aux
pouvoirs sixième mandat
ça fait 35 ans qu'il est à la tête du
pays on sait que d'ailleurs qu'il a
modifié plusieurs fois la constitution
pour pouvoir rester garder les rênes du
pays pendant la campagne électorale son
slogan était à bout c'est fini pour
toujours
est ce que finalement aujourd'hui ce
président est inamovible selon vous il
est là quelques battues bébé doc qui
s'attache au pouvoir mais sur mon cv ni
le drame est là c'est que il a bénéficié
d'un certain respect il faut des parties
de ce que les américains et plus de
partenaires des pays d'afrique r à
l'époque appelé les freedom fighters il
se battait pour la liberté se battait
pour une plus grande démocratisation de
son pays il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui il
elecam nom même de ce que les décors est
combat dans son pays donc c'est dommage
qu'ils soient passés de ce statut depuis
dans fighter à celui du dictateur
assumer et on ne peut que constater
cette nuit s'est opéré ils constataient
aussi tous les crédits dont il a
bénéficié par accident ces années là
c'est écrit des halls bien de me douter
aujourd'hui pensent accord youwin tr min
un cadenas tenir de leur pays incarne la
fois démocratique de leur pays
ce sont les élections qui auraient voulu
le dire mais il se trouve que cette
élection est qu elle est dans des
conditions telles que on ne sait pas si
elles sont véritablement l'expression
populaire est tout le problème est plein
de leader qui n'a pas de légitimité
populaire et été élu dans des conditions
ne peut pas véritablement mais les
questions à la fois de complot et de
l'adhésion de la corpiq internationale
qui aura du mal à vérifier stable je
voudrais que l'on reparle du score en
lui-même on frôle les 50 9%
quand on a des chefs d'état africains
qui restent au pouvoir comme ça pendant
plusieurs décennies on l'a vu
précédemment dans plusieurs pays ce sont
des scores beaucoup plus élevé
ils font aujourd'hui y'a juste voilà 9%
pour atteindre la majorité qu'est ce que
cela signifie selon vous en soit encore
à la soviétique comme monde muséal n'est
pas au problème
le problème c'est ce qu'il représente
est-ce qu'il est tombé ce score c'est
difficile de le vérifier et s'est rendue
difficile par le contexte dans lequel
les lexmark et organiques et je crois le
des problèmes aujourd'hui sur le
continent africain c'est pas le score au
fond les candidats ils soient en plaques
depuis 30 ans ou qu'ils arrivent à peine
au pouvoir le problème c'est que les
élections ne sont plus aujourd'hui la
garantie d'avoir un leader issus des
bureaux les élections en devenu un vrai
problème
surtout qu'il ya des crises pour aurel
qui survient après les élections tout le
problème est qu'on peut aller
aujourd'hui à organiser des élections
sans que ce soit un cas de troubles à
l'ordre public un pet de déstabilisation
pour les pays quoique tout les riffs
l'exploit de loi porté là dessus
les élections sont faites pour légitimer
un leader elles sont parfaites pour
plonger le pays dans une crise merci
beaucoup à louis keumayou d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes président du club
de l'information africaine